From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African-American History and Culture.
Today is Wednesday, June 8, 2011. My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with the videographer John Bishop and we are in Columbia, South Carolina at the home of Justice Ernest Finney Jr.
and we are here to do an oral history interview for the Civil Rights History Project which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian's National Museum of African-American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
Justice Ernest Finney Jr, thank you so much for sitting down with us and welcoming us to your home and this is Justice Ernest Finney Jr as well and it's a real honor and privilege to be with you.
Thank you. I'm delighted to be here. She had this moment with you.
Good bye, Koo. Let me take you back to begin our conversation with some reflection perhaps on your father and your aunts and you're growing up.
Well, my father was a school teacher primarily and my aunts shared the responsibility of rearing me since my mother had died when I was ten days old.
So it was a conglomeration between my father and my aunts primarily.
Can you say a little more about your father?
Well, he was an educator, a graduate of Virginia State University and he was teaching in Smithfield, Virginia.
And I was born in Smithfield and he was a strict constructionist, I'd say, if he were a lawyer.
But he ruled the roost in a fair and impartial manner.
As long as I understood that he was the boss and I was to do what I was told to do when I was told to do it.
But other than that, we traveled from one end of Virginia to another.
I don't know how many elementary schools I went to because all he had to do was get an offer of a better job and we'd have our bags packed within 24 hours and be on our own.
That's about how we got to South Carolina.
He had been teaching school in Virginia all of his life and when World War II began, he decided that he would go to Washington and work in the the Pentagon.
After a year or two there, he decided that he wanted to go back to teaching and he went to Baltimore where he taught at Morgan State University.
And while at Morgan State University, according to the stirs they told me he got a call from Claflin College in Orangeburg, South Carolina and they offered him a job in Orangeburg, South Carolina as Dean of Claflin.
And lo and behold, the next thing I knew I was on a train headed to South Carolina.
A place I had never been to had no idea the only thing I knew about it was the stories out here and the stories were told by my young friends who advised me that I was going to a place where they were probably going to end up lynching me.
But I thought they were telling the truth. When we got into Florence, the Pee Dee River, as I recall, was on one of its high levels.
And I said, oh my God, the conductor said, Florence is the next stop and you're changing Florence for Orangeburg, South Carolina.
I knew that this Orangeburg, South Carolina place was a place full of water and alligators and various and sundry other things.
But lo and behold, when I stepped off the train in Orangeburg, South Carolina, they were human beings, they were nice people.
And once I got to know them, they treated us as family.
And all the stories that my young friends had lied to me about were exaggerated.
So, when did you come down to Claflin?
I think it was 1946 or 45. I was a junior or something like that in high school.
Other impressions, you just said that the welcome you received by the community in Orangeburg, South Carolina and around Clapwell was a warm one.
Can you talk a little bit more about your impressions of the town, of the college?
Well, this was my first day and I was scared out of my wits. I was in a strange town, didn't know anybody, nobody knew me.
I didn't know what it was going to be like. But it proved to be a welcome that I was pleased with.
And within a year or so after I had arrived in Orangeburg, South Carolina, I had a job.
I went to work at the college soda shop as soda jerk.
And that was an interesting experience because the college soda shop was located right on the perimeters of two colleges.
And that was where the young people hung out and drank sodas and ate hamburgers and enjoyed life.
And the people were warm and friendly. The family that owned the soda shop was the Weber family.
And the Webers were instrumental in the business community. And they treated me as if I was a member of the family.
And I think I worked there for about six, eight years, something longer than that.
What was the African American family or what family?
African American family. How vibrant was the African American business community?
Well, I was very young. So I don't have any independent recollection of the high vibrant business community was.
But it was an active community. It was a community that was actively involved in the events of the total community.
One of the things I do recall doing my stay at Claflin, either the first or second years somewhere along in there,
the Ku Klux Klan paraded down the street right in front of Claflin and South Carolina State.
It was an interesting spectacle.
Were you and your father members of the church community?
Yes, we were. We were members of the Trinity United Methodist Church, which is located still right across the street from Claflin and State College.
So you enrolled in 48 as an undergraduate at Claflin?
Something like that.
What was your sense of what you hoped to do and be at that point as you could recall?
Well, at that time I had not formalized what my ambition was going to be.
I think I probably formally set my goals after we left Claflin and went to Morgan State.
I got an opportunity to observe these positions of black lawyers and how they were treated in the black community in Washington.
It was interesting.
So after your stay, after your studies at Claflin, you went back to DC?
No, no, I did not go back to DC.
But earlier, I had a few lawyers at Claflin.
So you had that sense of that gave you some sense that that might be a path?
That might be who I wanted to hitch my star to.
Oh yes, I worked in DC before.
I came to the Orangeburg, South Carolina. I worked in a shoe store.
Can you tell me a little bit more about how you came to observe black attorneys in DC in those years?
Well, my family was always reading and doing something.
And I remember there was a lawyer in Washington named Belford V. Lawson Jr, who was president of a fraternity, who was a national leader.
He was dressed always immaculately.
How I remember.
You entered in the fall of 52. You began your law studies at the college in Orangeburg, South Carolina, College of Law.
And the many parts of that experience that I'm interested in asking about.
Can you recall your sense of your fellow students and the faculty in the facility?
Well, the faculty was dedicated, hard working.
Sometimes you'd go to class, we didn't have, but about four students in the class.
Sometimes you'd go to class, wouldn't about to be the but you, the teacher.
And so you got individual attention.
And they did not play. They worked hard because I gathered from my recollection of that period of time.
The students and the faculty were out and about trying to make sure that South Carolina State University School of Law was able to produce the caliber of lawyers, which would justify its existence and make it a part of the history of Carolina.
And I think they succeeded very well.
One question I had was, do you happen to recall, I should have checked this before the interview, but I did not.
Do you recall what year the University of South Carolina Law School was finally desegregated?
I do not.
But it had not been desegregated and would not have been, I imagine, until maybe the mid-50s.
Somewhere along in there, because as I recall it correctly, one of the people responsible for the desegregation at the University of South Carolina was a student who was enrolled at the University of South Carolina State named John H. Wrighten III (likely) or John W. Wrighten.
And as a result of his activities, and I think he instituted a lawsuit which resulted in the desegregation of the University of South Carolina.
On graduating and taking the bar, that would have been early summer 1954, which was just then weeks after the Brown decision.
That's correct.
Do you happen to recall your reaction to Brown and its discussion on the campus and things?
Well, as I recall it, the reaction was ecstatic.
There was what we had wanted and what we had hoped for and what we hoped the Supreme Court would do in its decision.
And of course, there was some trepidation because we did not know what the implementing decision was going to be and it ended up being longer, taking longer than we had hoped.
Yes, we do.
Can you talk about what challenges faced a young African-American attorney in the mid-50s trying to begin a career in a life in South Carolina?
Well, it was strange because by and large there had been very few lawyers in South Carolina at the time I became a lawyer.
And it was a new experience for the black community as you would talk with them.
They didn't understand that if you were a black lawyer you could go into the courthouse and pull the books down and do the things that a lawyer would normally do in order to perform his services for clientele.
So, sometimes you take them to the courthouse just to show them you would walk in the front door of the courthouse.
And you would continually try to encourage them to get their students, their friends to submit their cases to you.
And I think one of the things that was most disappointing to me as an individual was the fact that there was with the establishment of the law school at South Carolina State,
the establishment of a law school at North Carolina Central University School of Law.
And these two schools in our view were similar.
But eventually South Carolina decided that in the exercise of its judgment that it was closed the law school at the South Carolina State.
And we had often wondered why?
Because as my information now tells me that North Carolina Central University School of Law has somewhere around 300 students,
it's a fully integrated and a full part of the legal education program of North Carolina,
where South Carolina State University School of Law has become a closed entity.
And to my perspective, it could have benefited, the state could have benefited if they had maintained that and that's one of the disappointments we have in our life.
Sure. I live in Chapel Hill just down the road from Durham.
So my sense of the history of Central's law school is just as you've described it.
And its history was almost equivalent to South Carolina State.
They were very similar, they created and very similar in their structure.
In fact, many of the faculty members from South Carolina State, when it closed up,
that's law school, went to North Carolina.
In the through the 50s, you taught school in Conway.
No, not through the 50s, I think, for about six years, early. Yes, I did.
What was that experience?
Well, I was a son of a teacher.
And so I had an appreciation of the significance of education.
And it was an interesting and challenging experience.
And it provided me with insights into the problems and dilemmas with which my student body was confronted.
Not only did I teach school, but in the evenings I worked with Dan in Conway.
And I picked up a job of two working at a hotel, then.
I know that there's a story sometimes recounted about your experience at a hotel in relation to the annual meeting in South Carolina.
That's a true story.
I was working at the Ocean Forest Hotel.
And when the South Carolina Bar Association had its meeting down there, I think it was in 1954, 55.
Blacks were not invited to attend the social events.
Though we were members of the bar, we could go to the educational seminars and things like that.
But my first meeting at a South Carolina South Carolina Bar Association, I went as a waiter at the Ocean Forest Hotel.
And somehow another of the words got out and later on in my career, when I became Chief Justice,
I used to tell the story that my first meeting at the bar was as a waiter.
But sooner or later I had acquired sufficient influence or connections or whatever you want to call it,
that I was at the head table at a future meeting of the South Carolina bar, which demonstrated,
to some extent, the progress we were making in certain aspects of the culture in South Carolina.
When did you, I know in 1960, you're going to move to Sumter and become very directly engaged in as an attorney and representing Civil Rights Planets.
But through that second half of the 50s, while you were teaching in Conway,
did you have much engagement with the network of black attorneys who were litigating those early civil rights cases?
Well, we did have a close connection between the entire black legal community in South Carolina.
And to the extent possible, with my limited capacity to be actively involved,
I did keep abreast and kept me informed.
In fact, it was as a result of a mission where Matthew J. Perry Jr and I. DeQuincey Newman came through some of the things
that were something that they were on their way to somewhere about the opening of a state park.
And that stimulated certain juices to flow.
And as a result, I made a decision that I was going to take my wife and two children,
and no one child, and leave Sumter and become a full-time fraction.
I love you.
Now, when I say full-time, I was reluctant to give up a full-time gig.
When I went to Sumter, one of the first people that communicated with me was the President of Morris College, Dr. O'Rouven.
And I was going to move and excuse me, was any thing that he thought that I could do.
And blowing the whole, he offered me a job teaching at the Morris College in South Carolina history,
which was right down my... I'm not even one class a week, two or three days a week.
And so that aided in my transition from...
Sure.
Towards Sumter and then.
Thank you, towards Sumter.
You mentioned I. DeQuincey Newman, and I believe in those years he was...
Field Secretary of the SC NAACP, yes.
Can you tell me some recollections about I. DeQuincey Newman?
I'd like to have a description of him in the record.
As I recall it, I'm getting older by the day.
But as I recall, it I. DeQuincey Newman was actively involved in whatever Chief Counsel Perry was involved in,
in the desegregation of the State Park that they were working on.
And I. DeQuincey Newman was actively involved in everything that was going on on the civil rights community at that time.
Obviously, in the...
We're going to switch tracks here for a moment.
Just that explosion of protest in early 1960 and how you then stepped forward to represent so many of the young people and others who were taking roles in direct action protests.
Ask you a question. I'll try to answer it.
Tell me about your recollections of the Friendship Nine.
Well, the Friendship Nine was a bit later on in the history.
The Friendship Nine, I got a call from Rock Hill, and somebody said that there are some students connected with Friendship Junior College that are about to do something that could cause them to be arrested.
And would I represent them?
And of course, I said, yes, I'd be pleased to represent them.
And they were connected with the Congress of Racial Equality, I remember it.
And the Congress of Racial Equality, field secretary, was a gentleman by the name of James T. McCain, who was very active.
And guess what? He was the citizen of Sumter.
So I knew him, and after receiving a call from the Racial community, I decided I'd go.
And the first time I got called to the Racial, I never will forget it.
My old ragged a car broke down. And there was a story written up in the paper which says that the Friendship Nine's lawyer was unable to get to court, and it had to be postponed.
Well, that was not as newsworthy. I don't know what they were doing yet, but I got to Rock Hill, South Carolina eventually.
And I got to meet these 10 or 12 students. And it was a simple demonstration.
As far as I knew, these nine people were going to be tried and get convicted.
And I would have gotten a bond, and they would have been out.
Well, somewhere, somebody had not fully informed their lawyer as to what they were going to up about it.
And, Lauren Behold, after we had tried it, and the judge had imposed his sentence, they then announced to me that they had a new facet of the Civil Rights Movement.
They were going to do their jail time and not put up a bar.
That was the first I knew about that.
Because in these days, the lawyers had to walk a fine line between what they could tell their clients and what the clients would tell them.
The first time I found out about jail without bail was after the conviction, as I recall it.
I knew I was shocked.
And I was shocked for a number of reasons. There was another organization involved in that Rock Hill, South Carolina community called SNCC, Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee.
I didn't know who was calling the shots for the students, but I knew I wasn't and wouldn't go let myself get boxed into instituting some lawsuit or being available or participating in that.
But they were ready to do what they were going to do.
And of the nine I recall, I think, no, the Rock Hill, South Carolina team was what I used to call them.
One of them withdrew from the demonstration aspects of that litigation because of his connection with one of the schools up there.
And his fact that he was an athlete of some kind and was worried that he would lose his scholarship.
Did you think of yourself then as being in your legal work for civil rights demonstrators most closely connected to your own private practice, to the state NAACP, to the legal defense fund effort?
How did you think about your connections as a lawyer?
You had to be as involved as you possibly could in all aspects of the community.
In other words, if you're going to justify your existence as a lawyer, you had to be in a position to articulate the concerns of the various citizens that you would represent.
I was most closely, I guess, identified with the NAACP because I knew the leadership and the better.
I knew that the Sumter, South Carolina NAACP was right there.
And the Sumter, South Carolina NAACP had a very active involvement in the total community.
In fact, one of the things that attracted me to Sumter, South Carolina was the fact that it had an active NAACP chapter.
And they were on the forefront of the leadership of the civil rights movement.
Excuse me, just one sec John Kelly Paws?
We're all working together.
Okay, we're back. We took a break to try to adjust some outdoor heavy equipment folks were doing some work outside.
Just to spend the only, you had just talked a little bit about your connection with the state NAACP and the Sumter, South Carolina chapter.
Can you talk a little bit more describe the volume of your work on behalf of civil rights protesters in the early 60s because you were quite busy.
Well, if you were going to be a lawyer and if you articulate the concerns of the Black community, you had to be everywhere at every time involved.
And we were a cadre of good lawyers, interestingly enough, most of whom graduated from South Carolina State University School of Law.
But they were hell-bent and determined to make the American dream a reality in our lifetime.
We didn't succeed in all of that. But of course, we diligently tried.
And every time Matthew and I used to talk about the fact that, I don't know if we talked about it or it's reminisced about it, we would say that if a Greyhound bus had a major wreck in front of our enemy,
our individual officers, we would not get the cases more than likely.
That they would end up being become a client of one of the more established law firms.
And we had to continually work to take the cases that were not significant financially in order to make a living and to serve our client there.
Exactly. In 1963, you joined the South Carolina Advisory Committee to the US Commission on Civil Rights.
Well, it was another avenue of opportunity for exposure and to connect yourself with a segment of the population that was not, you must remember,
that in the days we were talking about the headquarters of the White Citizens' Council was subterged.
And at the same time, as I recall it, some of the White community was very active in the Human Rights Commission.
I remember James McBride Dabbs was very active.
So you would affiliate yourself with everybody who might offer you an opportunity to become involved in the struggle for civil rights.
And you know, I told you earlier about the number of schools I went through as a student.
And I want you to know that I ran for political office three times.
I got beat three times, but I never lost faith in the system. So finally I won.
Indeed, in 1972, you'll win a seat on the state House of Representatives. But before I get to that, I want to ask out.
I'm very interested in two things. One, your perspective on evolving race relations in South Carolina through the 60s.
Voting Rights Act obviously gets passed. There's some early, some black candidates stand for election obviously in various races.
And then you will be a delegate, you are a delegate to the Democratic National Convention in the year 1968.
Those are two separate questions, but I'm interested in your perspective.
What was your sense of the nature of evolving race relations in South Carolina through the 60s?
We were disappointed that we did not make more progress.
And particularly, what we disappointed in the fact that much of the progress we apparently were making did not benefit the most needy of the black community.
And that's not an ancient story we're talking about. That's a current scenario that is still an issue.
We have, I think, I'm probably sighted at a couple of times. You come out of Spartanburg and you look at the schools in Spartanburg County.
And you come down to some of the less fortunate counties and you look at the conditions of our schools and everybody is talking about the Corridor of Shame and versus and sundry other aspects of our development.
But we still need to spend more time, more energy on developing a school system that provides an opportunity for our children in particular the less fortunate communities to get the quality of education which will prepare them for living in the next century.
In 1968, obviously early 1968, there's the horrible all the shootings at Orange and Orange Berk, the so-called Orange Berk Massacre.
And a year later, watching the federal government's reaction to that, and it's the next administration's refusal to open a re-investigation.
Not only did I resign, but a man by the name of Ben Payton resigned. I think it proved Ben. And several other people.
Because we felt that the federal government was not using all of its powers to see what the situation was and to investigate.
And I was chairman of the US Commission on Civil Rights at that time, I believe. And of course, there was always the struggle between the people who were in power and the people who were representing the denied people.
Not everybody. One side wanted everything done right then, and the other side wanted to say, let's wait and see.
How did you put your race together in 1972 for the State House of Representatives?
Oh, my gosh, how did I put it together? I was doing the same thing I've been doing for Get Out of the Street and talk to anybody, John, whoever would welcome me into a meeting.
And try.
Did it take a lot of money to run a race back then?
If it did, I wouldn't have been in it. I can't afford it. But the people who were something were good to me.
I had very few incidents where the underground of racial problems impacted my career, even the lawsuits I was involved in.
I remember the journalist Jack Bass. He interviewed you in 1975 as he was doing a series of interviews across the South about changing Southern politics.
And you talked in that interview about having pulled in your election, not insignificant portion of the White Book, maybe 20, 25% of the White Book.
That's all I needed. After losing three times, I...
We're going to put you on the back porch.
Yeah, you go out there with Rusty.
Justice Ernest Finney Jr is trying just to spend, perhaps, female modest in this interview. I can tell myself that's a little bit true.
More little bit true.
You helped found the legislative Black Caucus immediately entering the state house.
Yes.
Because upon being elected to the State House, I felt that if the caucus was going to be effective, the first thing we had to do was to learn the rules.
And in order to be a mechanism for good and change, you had to do that.
The only way I could think of to do that was to have a caucus where you meet and study what the rules are and be prepared to meet the rules here.
You know, that was why I was active with the other people who were in the caucus and formulating it.
You know, there's no need of us being at the shouting and carrying on if we don't know the rules.
Excuse me. How did you evaluate your years in the state legislature? Did you have your relationship with other folks who had the influence legislation?
Oh, yes. We became a force.
We were, there were three of us when I first got there, I think.
But we were a force to be considered when the agenda was being adopted or approved.
They got a little agentified going on over there now.
Believe it. They ended up in the Supreme Court this week.
Yes, they did.
Let me ask you now about, about 1985 and your election to the State Supreme Court.
A miracle still happened. You got to believe it.
I ran because some of my friends said we never had anybody who had in recent times.
And I thought I could win. And I ran and I won.
It was an interesting challenge and rewarding career.
Tell me about that campaign. What was involved in campaign for the Supreme Court in 1985?
Well, I had an inside track because SC House of Representatives 124-member chamber I believe, something like that.
The Senate had 46. And so I naturally had an opportunity to work on the House.
And the opposition was a senator. He worked on the Senate.
And despite the fact that he had been a legislator for more years than I had, that I had a larger number of people who were intimately working with me on a daily basis.
And that helped me.
In 1994, of course, there would be chose as elected as Chief Justice.
Yes. Can you recall that moment in your reaction?
Well, you know, I am a firm believer that if you provide people an opportunity and you do your homework
how can I say it? You will get a son vote.
And the people of the legislature elected me as Chief Justice.
I was shocked, pleased. But I have always believed that if you work hard, you will get your share of the vote.
You never did hear, ask me about my most famous race that I lost. Who was it that I ran for the South Carolina?
What did I run for?
Frances, do you remember what I ran for?
I got trounced. I ran for Congress. I forgot in the year. I forgot who it was.
I ran against the current Congressman, I believe. Right in campaign.
So I was just wild about politics.
What did you do when you were in the United States?
That's right.
I had forgotten about my most famous run.
Was it Albert W. Watson?
I don't recall actually.
I think it was Albert W. Watson. I'm not sure.
But I know that it was an open seat. I was a legitimate citizen. I could run. I ran.
Probably got 1,800 votes, but I did by the means.
So, like I was just sitting here, I used to be a journalist.
Huh?
Rob Chander?
Oh, well, you know, that was, that was, they were trying to hustle me out of South Carolina.
Probably, I was offered a job in the Justice Department.
By Robert F. Kennedy, then?
Yes.
But.
At least tell that story, yeah?
Well, you know, when you get back, that was a good gracious day. How many years ago was that?
All I remember is I received overtures from the Robert F. Kennedy that because of something they had heard in their room.
I remember that I could come to Washington and become affiliated with the Justice Department.
Well, I was enjoying myself where I was.
I was a member of the legislature. I was involved in my community. And that was where I wanted to be.
And I was not. I didn't know what Washington. I knew what Washington would like because I'd go into high school in Washington.
But I thought that South Carolina had been good to me and as long as they were good to me, I was going to stay here and work at it.
Let me ask you one final big question. It's about education because you've obviously been quite an advocate for education for a long time.
And as Chief Justice, you wrote in a case where you...
Abbeville County School District v. State of South Carolina. Good.
Yes, sir.
Tell me about it.
No, please, would you tell me about it? And us about it.
Well, let me tell you what.
Go back after short break.
Okay. Just a minute. We're talking about Abbeville County School District v. State of South Carolina.
Abbeville County School District v. State of South Carolina was a novel and involved litigation where some of the school districts in the State of South Carolina sought additional support financially.
And at the status of the case when it reached the Supreme Court, we were...
Those of us who felt as I do it, that we had to do something to number one, keep the case alive.
We didn't want it to end up being decided and going back and starting all over again.
Then I think I probably was enthusiastic that if the case was kept alive, the legislature's leaders would have resolved the difference.
The dilemma was that the legislative leaders by large were from large counties or from counties that had some basic support of education.
They had the tax base. And the smaller counties had the lesser tax base.
And so you were trying to walk a line where you keep the state involved in providing education and not give them something out that would have prohibited or stopped the state from supporting education.
And so I probably said the thing that I have caught the most flack about in my lifetime was providing...
It was almost as bad as separate but equal.
And they are still fighting that battle. They have not resolved that battle.
There is no way... It's going to be difficult to get the counties that have the tax base to share with the counties that don't have the tax base.
No, how they go justified to their constituents supporting those constituents that they don't represent.
That's the dilemma with which we will confirm it with.
I wanted to, even after you left the bench in 2000, you have worked...
You've done work, for example, with Richard W. Riley on efforts to kind of push back against voucher proposals.
And I'm thinking all the way back to say the most brown litigation and the question of tuition grants and how...
I wonder if you see a connection between that theme over all those degrees?
Well, I think what I see most is the fact that somehow another...
South Carolina is going to reach its potential and provide its citizens the kind of public education they need.
We have got to get to the point where public education becomes a crying need, a desirable result.
We haven't reached that yet.
We've got the latest controversy from Down in Charleston.
The company that is Amazon.
We've got to find a way that everybody in South Carolina has got to want to help public education.
I could make some comments about what we pay some of our public officials, but I think that would be inappropriate.
Any final thoughts, Justice Finney?
Well, I'm delighted. I'm having a nice time. My children are doing well and that people have been extraordinarily kind to me.
And I think probably the most difficult decisions I made were the fact that in my years in the legislature, I was unalterably opposed to the death penalty.
And as my career has gone ahead, I have had to sentence a human being to die. That was the most difficult of the inner struggles that I had.
My young man had robbed his grandmother and he had come into South Carolina and robbed a coin dealer and then raped one or two women.
And of course, in my new job as a circuit judge, I was assigned to try.
And the women he had raped, one of them lived, one died.
And that one who lived testified against it. In Horry County, jury determined that the appropriate sanction should be death by electrocution.
Now you're talking about hard, that was a hard day's work, but I had taken this oath tonight.
Yeah. Well, just spending a lot of money, I want to thank you so much for spending your morning with us and welcoming us to your home. It's a great privilege and honor for us and you thank me for sharing this memory.
Okay, you tell me what you want in the morning. I'll tell you what I can tell you. Thank you very much. I appreciate very much. Did I behave myself sufficiently?
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.